all right you guys
I don't know what happened like obs
all right can you hear me yeah I can
hear you yeah OBS is completely flunked
out I think I think my internet like
like had a had a moment and it caused
OBS to flunk out because for a second
there I couldn't I couldn't even hear
you so I don't I don't know what
happened there uh but but we we good now
we good now all right so I I guess you
want to just start back on uh you know
we started talking about on uh we have a
ghost yeah
yeah so we're apologize there guys you
know I don't know what happened there uh
sometimes obs it
they make it for so many things
sometimes I feel like it messes up I
don't know that's the first time it's
ever crashed like that though
yeah that's kind of crazy sometimes we
have audio issues that's the first time
it's ever just crashed because you two
usually it's a YouTube issue I don't
think that was a YouTube issue I think
that was an OBS issue but anyway let's
go ahead and move back on to the
conversation man we we were talking
about
we have a ghost and you know King hits
me up and asks me to watch this movie uh
so I did I did and you know I want your
overall opinions on the movie so far
first you know because I know that you
had a certain I I haven't talked to you
about this movie so I'm just curious on
your opinion on it all right um
first I had saw a trailer probably a
month ago because I'm always looking out
for you know what's new what's coming on
what we can watch right and then um
it was very very vague
because I thought it was like the last
movie uh with the Marlon one of
um the the Wayans brothers I think it
was Marlon who did like a ghost scary
Halloween thing and um and I said oh
they pretty much got something you know
popping you know with that too but
there's Anthony Mackey now Anthony
Mackey if anybody knows that he's a
Disney uh guy he plays the new Captain
America he plays the Falcon and I'm not
really a fan of Anthony Maggie I'm not a
fan of you know his acting and stuff
like that so reluctantly
I wanted to see this because I saw some
elements that I thought was funny
the lo and behold started watching the
film and as I'm dissecting the film
I start to see exactly what the film is
about
the film is about fathers
and
really not more so about a ghost the
ghost that just happens to be a father
uh well a father that happens to be a
ghost a father that has moved his family
around uh to try to find a place and
um
the the emotional toll that you see the
world's stress on a father
and expressing that through how they
deal with the world
all right so when you when you find this
ghost when after Anthony Mac and his
family moves into the house he has two
sons and his wife and they move in after
another family just abruptly leaves in
the middle of the night and the ghost
slams the door and they move into this
house that is haunted it's haunted by
this ghost and they don't know who the
ghost is but uh one of his sons
the the youngest one who's a major
a musician and he's a little eccentric
he's a little bit different he's not
just like every other kid uh he's into
his music
and that's pretty much what he cares
about he really doesn't care about
anything else and you come to find out
exactly why he doesn't really care about
too much other things later on in the
film but
it's the father is trying to make this
connection with his sons and he has a a
certain connection with the oldest son
but the oldest son kind of fits
the typical template
of you know a jock a kid that is
self-confident
it kind of seems like the older son and
the uh the dad just had more in common
than the younger son
and the youngest son
was a little bit more sensitive uh like
you know like his mother not saying that
you know he had uh feminine Tendencies
no nothing like that
um we call those uh those children
um
uh what is those children called uh not
emo children
um there's indigo children
right and india indigo children have a
different feel of everything that's
around them you know a lot of the
children that are born now are indigo
children and they have a sensitivity to
the environment have a sensitivity to
emotions uh you can't talk to them the
same way that you do uh children from my
era or the era right after my error
right so it's it's a different way that
you need to learn to communicate with
them and they don't react to the
environment the same with that being
said
when said young child and he's not young
he's in high school
all right so we don't have little kids
but um
when he interacts with the ghost
he's not afraid
he actually finds it hilarious
and this is the way that indigo children
see the world they see the world in a
different Spectrum not fear just
exploration and they want to understand
and they have emotions that tie to these
things so from that aspect when you when
you when you see that then you start to
understand okay this is going to be a
different movie but then you got to
start looking at the layers of the movie
and I just started finding different
things in different layers in the movie
that I didn't think that was going to be
there it is not a typical ghost film
it's definitely not that do not go there
thinking this is a ghost film that is
scary ghost film oh no there's moments
in it where there is pure hysteria
laughing when they have a medium show up
to the house and she's a fake fraud
medium and she gets a chance to see a
real ghost and it's really
steeped in our era now right
he like melted his head off or so that
was crazy right at first second there
I thought oh this this dude's more
aggressive than he he's letting on you
know what I'm saying but the kid kept
edging him on he told him hey he wanted
to give him edgy give me edgy give me a
little bit more because the ghost
was really not um uh malicious or
Maleficent they it was more
of a timid ghost anytime he was scaring
people he was scaring him get him out of
his space like he wanted to be left
alone because he couldn't remember he
couldn't remember and he couldn't talk
right so you can't remember and he
couldn't talk and he had a name that was
on his shirt called Earnest so the world
thought his name is earnest the ghost is
played by um the duty place I think Hank
and The Stranger Things yes so if you're
a fan of stranger things you understand
why Netflix uses a lot of the same uh
individuals because they keep a Common
Thread you know they find a core
audience that does like certain things
and you know he's a very likable
character and in this movie he didn't
disappoint you know this they don't
cinch her in the house so it's not a
house haunting this thing actually has
legs and has motion and it goes to
different locales it's a it's a this is
one of the films where it's uh has
something to do with a ghost and you
have a high speed chase that's something
that you would never see so
there's other aspects to this movie and
it has a tenderness to it as a
um
innocence to it
and it and it Taps into
the child nowadays the child that's not
being heard like how do you feel like
when you're talking to your parents it
made me take a reflection upon myself
like was there times when I was talking
to my children and I didn't hear them or
when I was too
um how can I say Generation X or
whatever Z whatever the hell I am and
I'm talking to an indigo child an indigo
child really doesn't understand me
yeah
um yeah you want me to go on this yeah
yeah yeah
you didn't like it at all tell me why I
just
with ghosts in it it's neither got to be
completely on the left his comedy or
completely on the right is horror I feel
like
this just didn't hit me on either side
uh you know I I almost filed I almost
fell asleep watching like I'm gonna be
around like it just I didn't know I
didn't like it at all either huh my wife
didn't like it at all either I just
didn't I didn't find no like
entertainment I I just felt like
this movie
was interesting in the in the fact that
it didn't know if it wanted to be a
ghost film it didn't know if it wanted
to be an action film like and I'm just
like come on man I didn't know if it was
going to be a teen exploration film
because there's Parts in it where it's
you know it's that teen movie where you
have that puberty moment you know the
the young boy and the girl you know and
the ghost is like
yeah it just I personally didn't like it
I thought it was a very average movie
like you know it's not saying that it's
a bad movie you know I I do feel like
it's got some Heavy Hitters in it and
yeah you know there's a lot of good
acting that goes on it but I just I
didn't feel like the story really
enticed me like for the most part the
moment after the story was over I was
grateful I think the only movie I didn't
like more than this
was that shotgun wedding movie I didn't
like that movie oh yeah I couldn't stand
the J-Lo movie yeah that movie was
horrible this movie's better than that
movie but not by much all right my my
thought on it is if you're a father
right now
foreign
the age right below it
um that generation
and you're having a hard time uh trying
to connect with your team
there's a scene
where
the father just releases all the bravado
and all that feeling like he knows it
all and feeling like he has everything
in control
and he tells his son
exactly how he feels exactly who he is
that he didn't know who he was that he
was unsure and he he was trying to find
himself and that's why they moved from
place to place and
and a lot of that stuff that he was
doing trying to find himself
he inflicted trauma
on to his youngest son
the oldest son was a little bit older
and he's there for the ride he
understands his pops a little bit more
but you know he explained to his son
that you know the night that he was born
that uh
it was it was raining just like you know
the night that they're standing there
and he just wanted to get him to the
hospital to get his mother there's his
wife to the hospital the you know son's
mother
um before she gave birth in the car and
he said if if God allows him to he wants
to be the best father that he can be and
circumstances changes things but I just
thought it was a heartwarming uh film
when it came to that so you know as a
person like myself who has daddy issues
uh this allows you to try to work out
those traumas and try not to inflict
those traumas on your kids because I
have kids and I have daddy issues so the
movie kind of talked to me in a way and
then the ghost
the ghost I told you as a father and you
know he has a kid and it's all centered
around the mysterious circumstances that
this goes uh seems to be on the other
end of being alive
so when the mystery starts to unfold and
the Mystery happens because it is a plot
twist to it and the Mystery happens and
then you actually find out exactly what
happened and what goes on and there's
some Ghostbusters stuff to it and it's
it's a sensitive moment where you get a
chance to see the insights of a father
trying to you know reach back from the
other side to his kid to try to find out
if his kid he was still here
trying to figure out what happened to
his uh pride and joy so it was a sense
of the film it was good I thought
Anthony Mackey not a huge fan of him but
this film
he pulled back a lot of that stuff that
I don't like the overacting
and I guess he played to his strength
and he played to his base
and it cast him in a perfect role so I
didn't like him in Black Mirror
um I didn't I really didn't like him a
captain in the uh Captain America and
Winter Soldier really don't like him in
Captain America but I really did like
him here so I mean this I guess this
bodes Wells for his career going forward
I guess uh he found a little bit more
depth to his uh acting chops and he's
actually giving a little bit more of
himself when it comes to the screen so
me myself I recommend it as something
that you could watch with your kids you
know um it's not anything that's going
to you know make you feel embarrassed
when you're watching them it's it's a
real you know three popcorn movie yeah I
put it on the equal footing his app man
[Laughter]
um
um but I thought it was uh like like I
said my wife didn't like it
but I did and I guess it's going to talk
to a specific demographic
and you know I guess I've been in his
shoes so I was sensitive to that and I
damn sure don't want to be in the ghost
shoes
so I guess I was sensitive to that but
other than that I thought it was pretty
decent and I thought it was pretty good
and I think it's something that's worth
a watch like if you if you don't have
anything you got you know you want to
sit down with the kids
just watch it or or if you just want to
you know tune in and check out something
that you might check out for yourself
you know it might it's a good watch
I give it a two I feel like I just it
doesn't hit like I think maybe you had
more to like sympathize with the movie
and you know have a little bit more
emotion towards it I didn't care about
the uh I didn't care about the ghosts I
didn't care about pretty much none of
the actors in the movie yeah I I didn't
care about nothing like it and it's just
like especially
when the ghost goes mobile that's all
I'm going to say
at that point I was about to turn this
off I ain't gonna lie to you King I was
about an hour hour
movie and I was like I think I'm I meant
it's a rap and I was like now let me go
ahead and finish it uh but you know it I
I do think look let's be wrong everybody
got Netflix yeah you know the majority
of the population seem to have Netflix
you know if you board on an afternoon go
and watch it you know we have ghosts I
don't think it's not worth watching
I don't think we've ever said anything's
not worth watching besides maybe Ant-Man
but but I I I don't think it's
definitely not one of those things where
we're having a conversation later on the
year I'm like man you should go watch
that we have a ghost that was a great
movie someone brings up we have we have
a ghost in like in like a Discord server
you know I must say
I didn't I didn't like it like
I mean I'm pretty sure that I'm gonna
get a lot of fathers that are having a
hard time uh that are you know my age
and trying to break that sensitive
barrier uh and understand I I highly
recommend you go look up indigo children
and it'll give you a greater
understanding in certain aspects of uh
how we deal with our children nowadays
because you know we tend to say that
they're really sensitive and um he was
uh really
belligerent and real rough with him
early on but it wasn't something that
was uh mean-spirited right it was you
know a natural normal ribbing from our
area our era and
that doesn't that doesn't work well now
it doesn't work well with children now
and if and if you watch the film and I
pointed it out to my wife that
the kid
has his own certain style his own
certain style of dress his own certain
style of uh attacking issues and it's
it's really thought provoking when you
actually just get a chance to watch him
act and I like him as a young actor he's
really good as a young actor really good
work that he put forth and I'm looking
forward to the next stuff that he does
do because he did strike me as a a very
well-trained actor him and uh his love
interest the um Asian um
oh girl you know what I think that
Netflix and that really do well uh for
well for the industry is they give a lot
more opportunities for people to get
noticed no yeah you know because it used
to be back in the day there's only a few
opportunities you had to get noticed and
if you wasn't noticing those
opportunities it was a wrap you was
doing b-rated movies I feel like Netflix
is gave a lot more people that wouldn't
have access to an outlet to act a lot
more acting opportunities and you know
that spawned Amazon coming around that
spawned uh you know peacock they're
having uh original exclusive stuff it's
about a lot of these little places that
we can actually look at these stuff and
you know really get a fill on what's
going on but you know that's pretty much
all that we got going on when it comes
to uh that movie like I said King King
gave it a three I think he's bugging a
little bit but it is what it is I gave
it a two I think that's the correct
score he gave it he okay so look so look
so look at me and looking at it
Eric doesn't have any children and
well we've probably got a little bit of
daddy issues but I got a little bit of
daddy issues and I got kids so I
identify with the kids and his kids in
the film so
I give it one more popcorn
I feel you I feel you
all right so let's talk about it man we
we are a little bit far uh behind when
it comes to
The Last of Us okay so we we got to do
two episodes today okay do episode six
and episode seven
I assume you've watched both episodes
king of course come on yeah I gotta I
gotta I got a question for you uh when
we get to episode seven but episode six
I pretty much remember from the video
game and it pretty much was pretty
pretty good I I mean it was other stuff
that was added to it to get them to the
space because remember they were going
to find Tommy you know this is the whole
thing they had to get to The Outpost
where Tommy was and by hella high water
he wanted to see his brother man he
wanted to get to his brother and that
was something good to watch it was
something good to see
but I want to talk about the opening
scene
with the p with the couple in the cabin
let's start with six though okay so
episode six was pretty much them finally
meeting up with uh Tommy uh you know
clearly the whole show has been kind of
directed going that direction and
I actually like this episode I felt like
this episode
it stayed true to the game to enough to
make me satisfied with it I still have
my gripes I still think that they're
intentionally staying away from violence
in a post-apocalypse world which makes
absolutely no sense to me
is that really true for this it's
definitely true about it really I think
in this episode really well there ain't
real no reason for them to be in beef
because they were in like a civilization
half that episode right and what's
what's funny is just like I think
that's my biggest gripe with the show
you know that I I do do with five with I
really liked episode one and two right
uh two started losing me there at the
end I did not like episode three because
of the deviated so much from the
original story right
um four was okay I really like five five
was a good episode uh six uh you know I
I think I think episode six showed that
you can deviate a little bit but still
maintain that that true point when it
comes to I mean they they still went to
school
how do you like the the character swap
for Maria
I I felt like that that didn't mean
anything like I know a lot of people got
upset with that you know I I get
some characters are so iconic that they
kind of have to stay a little bit
towards that that original like
aesthetic but I felt like Marie was like
a mid-tier person in the game right
where she wasn't extremely important she
wasn't like not not important so you
could easily change that without it
really messing too much up they didn't
have any kids so that's not gonna mess
anything up well yeah but you get what
I'm saying like you know when you when
you race swap too you know you got to
look at it changes the family too you
know
they did it to Joel in the beginning I
think they set it up in the beginning
with Joe's daughter being of mixed
Heritage I mean it's it's because I go
back and I play the video game and she
was blonde hair so yeah but I think the
reason you could do that well is because
it never really showed Joe uh uh Sarah's
mother
so you can extrapolate from uh the
child's uh uh color no no I I'm not but
I'm talking about in the game really
never really knew it so you can change
something like that it's not gonna
change anything drastically because you
never really knew who the mother was to
that degree so you could change that
very early on yeah but it's one of those
things where it's not there enough to
make a huge impact on the story
uh it didn't and it's just meme when I
go back to it right because right now
what I was trying to do and you know
Destiny want to pop up and Fortnight
want to have me finish off yeah I really
didn't want to do this podcast today
because of Destiny
everything that you're saying but at the
same time I had to watch this you know I
I got back home and I had to watch
um The Watchman color we have a ghost so
I watched we have a ghost for those two
hours all right when I was when I should
have been napping or when I should have
been playing Destiny but at the same
time
seeing this uh and playing the game and
going back in and playing the game
because I really don't remember the Last
of Us Part One as much as I remember the
Last of Us Part Two I remember the last
of us I remember key moments in The Last
of Us Part One
but Last of Us Part Two is still fresh
on my mind
so I I have a more more of a type that's
why when you hear me talking about the
the the genius of Neil druckman it's
really for the boundary kicking in that
he did for The Last of Us Part Two but
this episode here
eloquates the reason why I like it
because when he saw his brother when he
got there first of all I like the banter
between the married couple in in in the
in the cabin
and she he was like you made him soup
she was like yeah
he said are you telling me the truth
like it was just very witty very good
very old humor between a married couple
that's been in the wilderness Alone
Together Forever and yeah you can tell
that they probably are like alone even
before that were that yeah like he said
you know what I really like you know
that's pretty much all of episode six
guys they did they just get there they
talked to it's all I mean that's pretty
much the legit city of episode six but
they get to the they get to the the
job supposed to be yeah I I feel you uh
what I like about them is just
how
how natural the conversation was oh it's
beautiful where Joel was like puts the
map down and says point where we are on
the map and you better point where
you'll where where your wife and then
why he's like did you did you tell him
the right one and she's like yeah he's
like are you telling me the truth
I thought it was dope because you can
tell the wife had no no no no no FS
given like at all she was done with it
she's like he was saying they fed me
yes she she was so cute she was so cute
she was so cute it's like and she was so
cute in the grandma away was like it was
it was nice
and it's these little pockets of
um
I'll try to find a picture of him okay
it was these little pockets of joy that
you can find in this dystopian world
where everything is like crumbled or
crap but um they still had their love
they were still there like addict said
you could tell that they were with each
other alone before the pandemic and you
know they know where not to go
and where to go you know in the area so
they they told them don't go this way
but you know it ramped up a lot when
they did leave the cabin
and they were venturing off
and they made it to a river but they
thought that that first River was the
river of death but they realized that it
wasn't in the next River they got to was
the river of death and that's when they
got circled by the Posse and they let
loose a dog that can sniff the
um the fungus inside your bloodstream if
you're infected
and Joel is so see right now you're
getting the only picture I could find of
them cool
you're getting a chance to see Joel's
protective nature when it comes to Ellie
because Joe they're circled by a posse
of horses and with mounted horses with
guys with guns
and you know
Joel is like damn man we're about to go
out and if I gotta go out right now to
save this kid's life then he's gonna do
it and the dog they're so cute and the
dog went to go sniff you know sniff Joe
and he was fine
and then Joel thought they was out of
there but he's like nah the girl got to
get sniffed too
and he got really nervous yeah you know
her blood situation
and then she starts laughing over there
and you know she's playing with the dog
because remember she's she's a kid she
hasn't been out she was born when this
stuff was going on so she hasn't got a
chance to get outside she doesn't know
what the world looked like she has been
born behind the the wall
um and she's been you know occupied by
fedra
and and the situation has always been
Bleak for them so you know she's getting
a chance to see life and she's outside
with Joel and she really hasn't had
nobody there for her so and Joel has
lost his kid and he's he's his brothers
started a life because he finds out that
you know uh once they take him back to
the camera these are Tommy's people
let me take them back and he sees his
brother and
you know I mean Pedro Pascal man
he can act
like he generally
look like he didn't see this guy for a
long time and this was really his blood
and and it was good man
said do you think we get a flashback of
the brother story or do we get a do we
have enough of flashbacks
um
it was one flashback that I was really
curious about and we got that in episode
seven yeah we'll get to that here in a
second I I think Joe's did okay uh
Petra's been okay to being Joe but I do
feel like
there's better people that could have
played them I don't know like there's
certain times where I feel like I got
that Joe vibe from him and then there's
certain times where it's just like this
isn't Joel this is this is some random
other dude like but they they get the
appearance they get the aesthetic they
get a lot of you know
Behavior down but I feel like his
demeanor isn't there sometimes
no it no it's just that okay
it's mainly about just
the the energy that Joe put out in the
game you know like like it was one of
those things where I know you got me
trapped
but I ain't going down like that if it
went down I'm I might go down but I'm
taking some of you with me I I feel like
Pedro
though and I know it's mainly probably
script writing it feels like they're
pushing
his caring with Ellie too fast
because
I think
at that moment he shouldn't be that
extra already and and I feel I feel like
she didn't have to do too much to break
that wall down and and then the game
it was very hard for her to get Joel to
see her as anything else than luggage
you know what I'm saying right but
here's the pushback
we don't have that many episodes but
that's not my fault see see you say that
a lot but we got to play with what we're
given right yeah and what we're giving
in the game yeah you're giving mid
unlimited amount of time it's lukewarm
out but this right here with what you're
giving and what you're working with I
think they're building a good enough
thing because we know what happens right
we just need to know the journey to get
there and they've done enough to give us
a little bit of twists and turns but
let's talk about actual human
interaction actual human interaction at
some point in time and you're in this
world where you're alone and stuff like
that and you you're in charge to care
for something either you're going to
totally reject it or you're going to
accept it and I believe he got to the
point where there's an acceptance to it
because with the second bite
he's like nah man she's legit like this
is no BS this is 100 legit and I'm
believing I'm believing now and then you
start to get the caring I just feel like
Ellie's running this show it's not Joel
I I feel like there's too much lighting
because that just doesn't seem like Joe
Joe is all about look I know you don't
agree with some of the stuff I do but I
do it because I know it will protect us
but he just feel oh okay Ellie that's
fine okay Ellie that's right give me the
small crumbs
but I I feel like these Crumbs are
coming way too soon oh okay well so
you're talking about like all right so
let's get to the Crux of you talking
about when he decided to tell her that
you know Tommy gonna take you and then
he he he he he backed down on that I
think it's just mainly the entirety of
the show not just this particular
episode so you know okay so do you
believe and I and I believe this to be
true but this is just my assumption
because I'm a conspiracy theorist
um do you believe that your lack of
blood and a lack of following through
with what the game gave you is sowing
you a little bit more in a lot of the
awards that's in the show is really
irritating you more so than they would
have if oh the Well's definitely been
poisoned there's no denying that like
but but I've always been 100 since the F
the episode one right I want them to
respect the Lord now I will say the past
couple episodes they've done okay with
it you know what I'm saying but like I
remember the first episode one of the
biggest things I've seen Joe do that I
was like that Pedro do that I was like
that's Joe and so when he went up to
that guy hard in like episode one or two
it said yo you're gonna let me in that
room and that guard was like no I'm not
he's like and he just looked at him that
that stare that that that you know who I
am don't make me do it that is the Joe I
know but I feel like that's the only
time he's he's gave a hundred percent
making me believe this is Joel so then
it's raining
yeah I think so I don't think it's Pedro
I think it's the writing but it's just
fair enough it's up to the writers to
okay Joe I need you Pedro I need you to
to act this Persona a little bit you
know we need less of this and more of
this and I I you know maybe it's they're
giving a little bit more creative
control to the actresses and actresses
in general
yeah hold on let me get this five dollar
Super Chat uh from the black Harry
Potter my man I want to know who added
things would play a better job because
attic is tripping Pedro is doing
excellent I'm with you uh black Harry
Potter I'm with you 100 I don't know I I
saw I showed my wife Joel the character
in the game and she said yeah Pedro
looked like he was born well it's it's
it's not about the the the
Aesthetics I've conceded to that he does
look
he does look enough like Joel to pass as
Joe it's just the tone the demeanor the
the you know the vibe he's in the room
when he goes into uh a setting he's
always analyzing stuff he's always
looking for that exit out I feel like
there's not enough going on here like in
the Joe yeah doesn't act like that and
I'm not saying it's like hugely off but
I am saying it's enough off that I
notice okay yo we got a 45 Watson we got
18 likes come on I know we kind of
messed up in the beginning but come on
man save the pandas man come on man hit
that like button so
so I mean I guess I guess what we'll do
is we'll go into episode seven uh
well we didn't even finish episode six
because they get over to the facility
and they find out these dudes Don't Clap
and got out of it but Wally inside you
got what you was looking for didn't you
add it you got a little uh human on
Human Action pause
let's go I feel you I mean when it comes
to to like the actual School scene
um
it it was it was okay right but like my
things man but
oh
it just there's no interaction man
there's no human interaction but we've
seen the effect of like twice this whole
show it feels like
no
okay we've seen it once in episode five
right we we've seen demeanors of them
here and there but we haven't really
seen I've seen the affected in episode
one we saw did we see effect what I said
like two I was being I was like I
obviously I didn't mean literally twice
oh okay okay I'm saying off of a show
that isn't a post-apocalypse world
I still do not feel like this is a
post-apocalypse world
hmm
I think we have a limited amount of
episodes
but once again that is not my problem
that is their decision to give them
eight nine episodes that's not my
decision my decision is you would have
built up more of a of a of a narrative
Focus around what's going on look
episode six was good I actually think
that was more one of the better episodes
that's happened in the world but as far
as any popcorn you give episode six
because obviously episode six is already
a done deal to you
I give it a three
what
I I'll give it a three hey
they talked to the to the to the old
couple in the beginning they they set
they set it up nice for you you get to
the part with attention when you think
the dog is gonna bite Ellie and they're
gonna shoot Joel in the face but then he
doesn't Tommy's people and they get to
Tommy and Tommy says you know for his
brother he about to ride out for his
brother and leave his pregnant wife here
Tommy don't want to go but Joe said I
ain't got it in me man Tommy I no longer
that trigger oh man that's that's not it
that's not it I'm sorry it's not it oh
man my thing my thing with this show is
I want more of
five dollar subtract from the black
Harry Potter so who would play the role
better at it because you said I feel
like some folks could have did a better
so who
good sir
um here's here's my thing the black
Harry Potter it ain't my job to find out
who's going to play the role better okay
when when when Robbie Downey Jr ended up
getting cast in his Iron Man I couldn't
have told you he would have been a good
Iron Man I don't get paid thousands of
thousands of huge salaries to go out
there and cast people but they do I'm
not saying that Pedro was the worst cast
they possibly could have done I think
he's a decent good cast and then mainly
the the the the the harps I have against
the show has nothing to do with Pedro
it's how he's portraying Joe as a
character just because the man looks
like Joe to a degree does not mean he's
acting like Joe the way you would have
seen it in the actual game
I rest my case
so uh black Harry Potter he can't find a
guy but I'm not looking though like this
you gotta give a for instance if you're
gonna say is other people that could
play a better role I say this right and
I'm gonna get you off the hook really
easy
he's the best dude that can play Joe
oh with the star power and everything
involved with him
the script that they've given him and
the the direction that he's getting
is not good enough for you how about
that
I I just
I personally feel like he does a decent
job at playing Joe it's just certain
times he's breaking Joel's character and
yeah and that's what I'm saying it's not
Pedro it's it's the writing it's no
drupman
um I I personally feel like the show has
been it is a shell compared to the
violence that was actually in the game
which if people oh you know you don't
need all this violence it's the
post-apocalypse world that has been took
it over by bad people and infected
people I'm sorry but violence comes with
that
I hear you but we got violence at the
end of episode six and Joe gets stabbed
and got like a little uh
hold up hold up hold up he got it he got
hold up he got attacked
he punched him into a tree and then Joe
got stabbed Joe literally
took him by there was no beef there was
Joe just handled it that's all yeah he
got handled too and people say oh he
doesn't need I see on Twitter people
saying he can't be a John Wick just
going around no one asked for that but I
do feel like every aspect that the show
does they intentionally go away to make
sure that there's not much violence if
you really think about it God is on your
head boy
Harry Potter that's fine if you really
think about it
in a post-apocalypse world in the kind
of in the kind of you know environment
that's going around Pedro uh Joe in the
in the last of us uh show he has killed
like five people maybe six
in all of the episodes but in the game
because I don't even think he
that's fine there's a lot of people that
I would say the most he's killed is 10
by far but he killed infected man we
gotta add infected in that too man he
was shooting them no we can't see but
they have no problem showing the
infected getting killed right they have
no like they have literally replaced
times for humans were supposed to be in
the game in the show with infected just
to make it more it's more palatable a
lot of people oh my God man the kids
need to watch this is the first time
that a post-apocalypse show
has had this less violence it's like
it's like they're literally on the bad
side of West Virginia
and they're in their and they're driving
around these back streets and they're
actually not in Apocalypse they just
they they the the the the episode five
if you take away that episode you can
argue that this really isn't even in a
post-apocalypse world I'll cut it up all
right so you gave it how many popcorns
I'll give this episode three popcorn I
give it a four
it's not a masterpiece but I did like
the set pieces that they did have into
it and I do like the fact that Joel
understands he's not the man that he
used to be and he realizes it was a bad
choice for him to come downstairs and go
with Ellie because Ellie didn't even
give him a shot to say you can go with
Tom Joe let's go gave him the book bag
we up out of here jump on a horse and
Joe gets stabbed
do that dude but Joe stab because he
lost and that's another thing why did he
just have Tommy go with him
why didn't you happen that happens later
that happens in in the last of us too
what happened oh God they're gonna you
know I hope they butcher that story
because I know you love that story you
know I see and then you're gonna have
two different people here because if
they if they get it get a hold of Abby
first of all if they messed up the
casting of Abby I'm probably not even
gonna watch
I'm Gonna Keep it a buck with you and
you know what I gotta do because I I
don't talk this game up I'm getting
smoothie up so much this to show up so
much the last of us too that I gotta
play it and let my wife watch me play it
because she she's like oh I want to know
this this Abby that you so in love with
and I explained to her it was a journey
of the character that uh I was so in
love with it was the you know revenge is
an empty vessel and uh when you go
looking for Revenge make sure that you
dig into graves because when you're
digging that one grade for that one
person you're going in the next grade
because you're not gonna make it out of
that situation and she hated the person
that she turned herself into when she
found that revenge and she found that it
was Hollow and her life had no meaning
after that situation and she just
followed the Road to Redemption
and she didn't want to go back to the
old Abby and you know that cost a lot
she lost a lot in the game and it
allowed me to see it through a person
who's seeking act I'm talking about
truly seeking reject Redemption not a
person that's looking for Redemption for
uh you know um I guess for the people
around them no for her inner self and
her soul so I felt that and when when
certain things was happening I just
really fell for the character and I
thought it was a real good game
probably one of my best games ever to be
honest with you story wise uh good
pacing good stuff in it I know a lot of
people have problems with it I really
don't care about what they feel about it
because it was my money but again I said
that is probably my best game because of
that character and an interpretation of
a said character but if they butcher
that I can tell you I will be on this
show
telling you that they're done all right
now I I would have dropped this show two
or three episodes ago if it wasn't for r
r i part of me wants them to butcher
that just so you have to sit there and
watch something you don't want to watch
so now that we have given it a four and
a three popcorn yes Joe I gave you four
because you took a belly a stab to the
belly and I respected because you was
trying to save Ellie all right so you
know what
it's time that we go to episode seven
you know I first off this this was the
DLC uh okay yo that was my first
question to you I never got a chance to
play the DLC at all
right and really I'm going into this
episode completely blind because it was
a question that I've always had
regardless to what because remember I I
had picked up the The Last of Us the
first one the was it the Remake the
remastered the remaster is the one that
they just upres and put out on the
PlayStation 4 right and the Remake is
the one that they did for the
PlayStation 5 right yes all right so I'm
gonna buy because I got to read the the
remaster I'm gonna buy the Remake
because I I picked up the last plus two
again for my PlayStation 5. and and I
started playing the demo of the
remaster
I think the that game looks so
incredible
it looks absolutely incredible it's
certain things that they did you know
we're using some technology from The
Last of Us too
that they used over there higher res
stuff so when I was watching this
episode I really didn't know anything
about it because it was the DLC and the
DLC had came out and have long moved on
from that but now the DLC is available
inside the original packaging I'm going
to check it out so I really I can just
give you my synopsis on how I feel about
the episode but you can give me it as a
correlation to the game and the DLC that
you did play because you did play the
DLC yes yeah
um they stayed pretty close to the game
you know there's stuff to the deviated
from but for the most part uh it was
pretty close now here's like scenarios
where
in the game
when they were found by the infected
yeah it was mad of them and they were
running through the mall trying to get
away from them you know what I'm saying
right they didn't really do that on here
and like another thing it's like
there's just one infected here and I get
it but it would have been a lot nicer
and a lot more because I think when I
get annoyed is when there's decisions
made
that the game did better but for some
reason they deviated like I get it one
did the same thing in all in all sense
it was just one that chased them around
like one little place and then it ended
like in the game like I said that it was
aggressive boy like in the game they
were running through the whole building
trying to get away from a swarm of them
yeah but see the game was trying to sell
you on time and content and trying to
stall you out whereas this is on a uh
once the the clock starts it's you know
45 minutes to the end of this thing and
you know having a horde really wouldn't
make any sense because she only has one
gun you had a couple of pipe bombs
um you're really limited on exactly how
you're going to dispatch these uh
characters so I feel one zombie or one
infected would have done the trick
especially if he was aggressive as this
one was because he was hella aggressive
I just personally feel like it should
have been the other one I know you can't
wait for the Last of Us dude
because it's just like to me
you needed to tell me that this chick's
in the fireflies and it was two on one
and this one infected was able to get
both of them
she was just she was fresh into the
fireflies man she just came out of uh of
ephedra like a week or two ago she was
going for like a week or two and she
she's she's about to ship out she's what
17 years old I like the episode I just
personally feel like that particular
scene
I don't understand why they changed it I
do time constraints what was the rest of
the time they just walked around the
mall put nothing to the plot of the show
but it's just showing you how Ellie
okay
how some parts of her that will show up
in The Last of Us unless you if you
never saw the DLC it shows up in the
last of us too
the Genesis of certain things
right and how that was explored
so I'm really curious to play the DLC
now based off of this episode that I
didn't see so this was it was a good
episode though besides that little Knack
thing that that I felt like they could
have done better
um I I actually enjoyed it I felt like
it was well paced you know what do you
think about drinking Dead Man's whiskey
though
that was disgusting and the fact that I
don't know what he had going on I don't
know if he he they don't even know what
killed him for all you know the backwash
could have could have affected that
that's what I'm talking about it's it's
nonsensical but I guess they felt that
the alcohol killed the whatever was in
it now it doesn't make any sense thought
since they fit they spent 15 minutes
or later I feel like yeah
because see they they grew up
in the behind the wall they was told
that the mall was full with infected
she's never seen escalators so stop
coming you know it's a funny thing
though
that they why what what world they grow
up in King
a dystopian world what's in the dystopia
World a post-apocalyptic world and what
what started it
the the effect and why don't we ever see
the effect we saw one one was on we saw
one one one he was on them you needed to
tell me that you got all these people in
this town and no one feels like they can
go explore in the mall I want to know
where they all went though because they
said
it was over there I go listen I'm gonna
I'm I'm a hundred with you I felt that I
just feel like
I feel like if they would have just had
like the same episode make it like five
minutes longer and just have the last
five minutes then running through the
mall up to the roof like was in the
original game
that would have made a way better you
know a lot of more action Paces in it uh
like I said this
this is this episode was decently paced
but right it's just once again I I I I
feel like they're in like an abandoned
town called Silent Hill and they're
walking around the mall like like to me
I just don't understand why all of the
violence is downgraded and why the the
appearances have infected is that is
that almost done like episode five made
me feel like it was an apocalypse made
me feel like there was actual fear at
every round of every corner I was
terrified in this episode the majority
of this show make literally makes me
feel like they're in an abandoned Town
that's in West Virginia that's literally
what it makes me feel like well I was I
was terrified in this episode because I
knew it was one infected one or two went
there there was too many Dark Shadows
and I said they're playing this music
too loud they're in the arcade having
too much fun and somebody gonna bust
through and bite them something gonna
happen
and I always wanted to know how Ellie
got bit I mean I've always did and you
know um
now shout out to them for for giving
this episode that I I got a chance to
see that I always wanted to know the
Genesis of her uh coming out and you
know the fear of the kid uh coming out
to somebody else and which was her best
friend but you understand why they had a
bond now and you know she was leaving
and she wanted her to go with her and
you know it was it was heartwarming at
that point but then you had
philosophical differences whereas she's
like well you become a terrorist and you
know
I didn't like her reason for becoming a
terrorist yeah dog got a point how you
finding uh how you not find an iPod but
find a Walkman
hey hey hey King tell me you didn't
notice the big Sony on that walk well
basement man item placement I had that
one
come on man
Y'all Gonna Act Like a lot of this stuff
isn't set in a in a world that kind of
makes sense
it kind of makes I like how they had
more combat in it though you see what it
is is
he's looking for an iPod but iPod wasn't
made yet
right no they they you see the trucks
and cars that they was driving hold on
what what year someone put in the chat
so 20 years from now would be 2003
but before now it'd be 2003 because
they're supposed to be in our time frame
hold on hold up let's see let's see I
don't know man
I don't know when was the iPad created
they was playing when was the iPod
created
October 23rd 2001. according to
Wikipedia oh so there was two years out
they didn't make it over there that was
a real sound bro that was too high
that's me
sorry you get a walk man I mean I
personally feel like
there's probably it they could have been
technology like that but walkman's you I
don't know because I they they had power
I gotta you since you want to do that I
got to find out when did Mortal Kombat 2
arcade machine come out
see 1993 plenty of time there's a
there's a reason that's in there I'm
just gonna say
at least the this man or the Walkman
sport yo for real my wife was like yo
remember the yellow one I was like yeah
I had the waterproof Jimmy with the
gray buttons
the stupid thing about the waterproof
one
the headset wasn't waterproof
you're ridiculous all right so you know
coming into it you know what what was
the things that you enjoyed about this
episode because I I like that you're
coming from the concept of someone that
didn't play the uh the DLC but you
played the real the actual base game
yeah that you're watching this because
you still have that experience from the
real game as as Ellie but you don't have
the experience of you know this
particular DLC this experience I heard
about it right
um and somebody they kept saying yo man
you got to try to DLC and I think when
Sony made it available and I guess they
made it for free if you brought the re
the remaster
um then you were you were cool and I was
like all right I got it I have it there
and I saw it I was like you know I'll
download it and play it after I play the
regular game and then um just never got
around to it and then seeing this
because you have questions you know and
I guess Neil Brooklyn thought to let me
go back and just fill in some of the
gaps for certain things and from all
intents and purposes I think he did a
good job because from what you're saying
is that you know he uh kept it pretty
much the same except for the fact that
instead of one uh uh zombie it was many
well well there's a lot of changes but I
don't expect them to keep everything
one-to-one right it's just this is
mainly just I would want to feel like
this is an actual apocalypse that's
that's probably my biggest criticism in
this show is there's very few times
where I feel like at any time people can
just start dying you know what I'm
saying like it always feels like they're
in controlled environments and you know
they're always in some form of because
the majority of the show has been
outside of civilization walls but it
doesn't feel like they're outside
civilization walls it feels like there's
still in them and like let me put it to
you this way okay Attack on Titan
you feel comfortable the moment they
lead them walls you know at any moment
something can go down you took my bars I
was just about to say it feels like
Attack on Titan and I know what you're
gonna say when they outside those walls
on Attack on Titan because you told me
yo as soon as they get outside the walls
it's gonna get real and I'm like
whatever and then get outside
it got real so I know I'm I'm expecting
it to get real I don't know man it's
somebody's judgment call you know
somebody someplace is pulling the
strings and I guess you know sometimes
you gotta you know eat the meal that's
put in front of you sometimes it's it's
palatable sometimes it isn't I thought
this episode was it was pretty decent it
answered the question that I had for a
long time and I think it told a good
story with a lot of tension in the
background for me uh the fact that they
were playing in our shade and she
thought about it and she did all these
things to get her there my main question
is
the the infected heard them playing in
the arcade machine but she said the
night before she setting everything up
uh of course she's in you know she set
everything up
he didn't hear it
you know so and she was said she was
living there for like a week or a month
or something I don't know how long she
was there like two weeks something like
that but
at no point in time did the infected uh
feel a presence noticed that she was
there and felt the need to go and seek
out you know uh another person to infect
I just found it you know again you know
a little hole in in the thing but
it worked to tell a story I guess
yeah and it's like I said I don't want
people thinking that you know the past
couple episodes I I was I was happy with
it like I'm not gonna I don't think that
the show has had like a huge dip it's
just season two I just want it to feel
like an apocalypse like imagine having
The Walking Dead and you don't see
zombies the first season rarely like
walking dead the first couple Seasons
you could say what you want about later
on in the show and I think a lot of that
a lot of that criticism is valid but the
first couple seasons one of the reasons
that that show succeeded is they kept
the viewer on their toes because at any
moment a horde can come by uh humans
could come by there was a lot of
variables to be scared over and this in
this show I just personally feel like I
haven't had a moment like that I haven't
had a moment where I feel like at any
time you you know we could see some
running uh infected or anything like
that I feel like you wouldn't even know
if you just came in there and you just
watched a random episode here that's not
like episode five or episode one to a
degree you wouldn't even know this is a
a show about infected uh humans
this is true
um I think they're trying to just build
up on the Joel Ellie aspect and the fact
that she is the Messiah to uh give you
know the the cure to the plague that's
plaguing the world
yeah so I mean that that is what it is
on that but what the beggar beggar the
better question is what what ratings man
what how many popcorn are you giving
episode seven of The Last of Us
hmm
I found that a lot of a lot of things
strange I thought it was a lot of holes
in a lot of the stuff
um
I I got a chance to see Ellie's mindset
and her level of disappointment when
things happen to her
I I struggle to give it
a four
I I could give it a three
but on the merits of the acting and and
so you want to give it like a 3.5 is
that what we don't have that so I can
make it you can give it no no is it
three or four
but you know I got to give you my
reasons why a four a three and a half
pop nah nah I'm not giving no half
popcorn have you ever served me I have
popcorn I'm gonna throw it at you I
won't either three or four but you gotta
think right
how hard is it to just act off another
person
and for the most of the episode it was
just these two acting off of each other
and they did a good job
I really haven't liked the character the
the person that's playing Ellie like I
really never did I never brought into
her being I'm starting to I'm starting
to really
she's starting to grow on me like this
is why I I still don't like her at least
as far as like Aesthetics and I feel
like at times she kind of breaks Ellie's
character because I feel like Ellie in
the game is more mentally strong that
Ellie in the TV show Ellie in the game
didn't care about anything don't you
think that the the the girl from the
brella Academy would have played a
better Ellie but she's too old
I feel you and apparently they're
they're gonna bring her back in season
two
oh God
whatever
um hopefully she you know she doesn't
anyway
um
yeah yeah I she's growing on me
uh but at the same time
I'm gonna give it a three pop one
I'm gonna give the episode a three
popcorn for
the Lost potential that I saw that was
there right and I'm not going off for
the DLC because I didn't play the DLC
I'm just going off of fresh eyes a dude
that's looking at a show and I just
thought that it was a potential there
that they didn't uh capitalize on but
they did answer a question for me they
in
I I really wished
that they would have gave the episode at
least 10 more minutes
till you can see the study Decline and
The psychosis that sets in on Ellie
while she watches her best friend slash
love interest descend into madness and
does she have to kill her best friend
or she has to lock her up inside the
mall and I really wanted to see that and
I thought they ducked out the window and
I swear I would have liked to have seen
when Ellie realized she was immune like
right but we wanted it was getting worse
one of them's not she's like why is this
going on because I feel like that's
something they never really brought on
and we could talk about when it comes to
the video game they kind of ignore the
fact that Ellie's immune I still don't
know why they done that because it
because that's a huge moment factor that
you have to take into consideration that
this is an individual that is the only
person in existence of of that you know
of that is immune to the disease and I
felt like in last of us too they kind of
like we're gonna ignore that's happening
now like yeah but we're gonna but again
at that same time remember she put a
tattoo on top of it and she pretty much
uh covered what the scars look like I
want to know who the hell gave her the
tattoo but again
um that's something that we'll get to
when we get to the last of us too what
so what did you give it at it
I think it's uh
let me give this a four
um I actually really enjoyed the episode
you see this people when he goes three
when I go full when he goes uh four I go
three it's just I was I'm stuck between
three and four right but I feel like
this like at this point it's addict how
much did you hate the show I didn't I
didn't hate this episode so to me
they did enough to keep me interested in
this episode that six did and they just
carried on with this if six wasn't a
good episode this probably would have
got a three because I felt like I was I
I was in because I've watched them back
to back remember
so I had two hours of greatness well
goodness I wouldn't say greatness I had
two hours of goodness but most the time
when I watch these episodes The Last of
Us I'm complaining at the end of it
I feel you
I feel you so you you know that's pretty
much all when it comes to Last of Us
episode seven uh like I said definitely
HBO Go watch that man uh I I think the
show's good it's just
I feel like the longer the show goes on
the more people are starting to turn on
it because I do I feel like this week no
one talked about it well you notice that
it fell off the charts as far as YouTube
algorithms and people running around and
talk show hosts uh talking about it
because
the backlash that they received so and
one thing I will say you can say what
you want about the Halo TV show yeah but
at least they put they're in a war you
know what I'm saying you actually feel
like you're in the Halo Universe it's
just they messed up a lot of incidences
February 28th 2023 addict says something
positive about the Halo show in uh
opposition
to The Last of Us I find this as a
seminal moment and I would like to take
a bow
I
I still don't like it
but what I will say is when it comes to
the like the environment they do make
you feel like they're out of war with
the Covenant you know what I'm saying
you hear it it doesn't seem it really
doesn't and to a point what I will say
is there was more people talking about
Halo at this point than there was about
last of us I really felt like no one was
really talking about last of us this
Sunday no they weren't and I'm with you
I mean I saw a lot of people fall off
from it I guess you know certain times
you know you're not going to get ratings
but what you're going to get from the uh
r r with the Lord is you're going to get
consistency you understand if we don't
like the episode if it's not ratings we
are gonna cover it anyway because we
have a commitment to y'all yeah you're
always going to get situations this is
what you can you can look forward to
every week me complaining about the show
and King being in the middle
okay
it's just two people what's up
um
this week we have uh two films right uh
we have the guy Richie film that's
coming out uh I forgot the name of a
something operation and uh we have Creed
Three
I on the other hand have the unlimited
pass and
my movie theater has 18 screens so I'll
be driving down the block to go watch
both of those things I'll take my son to
go see uh uh well my son and my wife to
go see uh Creed Three and I'm gonna
check out the guy Richie film probably
on Monday Monday yeah we'll check out
the guy Richie film on Monday uh to see
what that's about uh I really tend to
like guy Richie films and
um
it's uh it's it's probably one of his
best films from what I'm hearing so and
you know he he does really good stuff so
it's it's going to be something to talk
about so you know next week I'm going to
be talking about Creed Three uh
hopefully we can find a solution for
attic to get this uh to you know so he
can do his homework oh I'm going to find
something on Netflix HBO oh Paramount
that was there was a movie that the chat
brought up that was on Netflix so is
someone in there
um that I think it was earlier right
it's called Uh the platform okay
I don't I don't know what that is but uh
I'll put it right here in my catch when
we get upstairs I'll uh check out the
platform yeah so I will watch the play
you know what I think we should start
doing you know we can give our senatics
obviously on here but
I think what would be cool is if we
start putting like
more in-depth reviews
on patreon and stuff and like uh stuff
like that so we'll talk about it uh
going on that obviously we're still
going to talk about it on here but oh
you know there's only so much we could
do like I'm talking about like the day
it happens you know what I'm saying okay
because there's more because when we you
get that live thing okay I just watched
it so right let me go into that and I
think that's the more the most thing I'm
talking about uh but you know I I think
first off you know I want to say thanks
forever for coming through we had like
up to six
yeah yo on God J uh Jay gaming uh 19
what is it 1986 Pinocchio's on Netflix
I've heard some stuff about that
Pinocchio and I definitely want to watch
that Pinocchio I'll probably watch that
Pinocchio right now before I go to bed
so that'll probably be something I'll be
talking about uh because I heard good
and bad things and I I always like to
have my own opinion don't like to have
anybody try my food before I eat it so I
definitely want to talk about it so I do
want to see Pinocchio I'm a huge
Pinocchio fan uh ever since a kid and if
you go back and watch Pinocchio now as
an adult oh it's a twisted story
yeah and I just put the patreon in the
chat now I do want you guys to because I
feel like there's a lot of people that
are are part of the patreon and they've
been there for a while and you're
missing out on a lot of you know
different moments to get on the shows
man where are the people that you have
the opportunity to be on IOP or or you
know or RNR with the Lords or you know
you got Shazam coming up on the 17th
it's a lot of stuff that's popping and I
mean wouldn't you want to be in a square
too you know we could put you in the
center screen have these conversations
we can talk about this stuff patreon is
there you want to ask us questions like
hit the questions
yeah so I feel you on that so like I
said okay patreon's in the description
well in the in the chat go click that
especially if you're already a patreon
uh what a there's so much that you guys
aren't having access to right now that I
I feel like you need to go over there so
definitely go check that out uh patreon
well uh right now we have a five dollar
tier where you can ask any of the any
question one question to any of the
shows we have we have a seven dollar
tier where you can see live reactions
that me and King do and you have a 10
tier where you can ask us to react to
something so definitely go there uh you
know I think we're we're trying our best
to be better in terms of bringing value
to that service and I think you guys
will enjoy that uh but you know that's
pretty much the whole show like I said
patreon in the in the comment section
below uh I will be uploading this to the
to the r r channel uh you know if you
guys want to go over there and sub there
and we'll see you next week we'll talk
but a lot of stuff hopefully we'll be
able to talk about Creed for the most
part until I find out what's going on
with this I'm probably only going to be
watching like the big big stuff like
scream
um
a pro probably screaming like the Marvel
movies like Guardians of the Galaxy yeah
because we got to manage stuff until I
figure out a solution but I'll be
talking about everything I possibly can
get my hands on because I'm gonna
squeeze the hell out of this wrinkle
unlimited well I'm just referring to
like a full-blown spoiler cast okay yeah
for sure yeah because we can't do that
so it's just really gonna be good and
plus you know there's a lot of stuff
going on too uh we will be at PAX East
next month yes oh no it's this oh no
it's next week well it's next month we
sell on the 20th we on the last day yo
check this out
um I want to thank the black Harry
Potter definitely for the super jets
listen anytime you super chat over here
those that actually helps us on the road
to packs uh get into packs and get into
our goals so I just want y'all to keep
that in mind it's not just necessarily
over there when you uh I don't I I don't
believe when you super chat on the
addict show it goes over there too right
no all right so but when you Super Chat
On Combat talk with the King when you
super chat on r r with the Lords and
when you super chat at ILP
um I lost podcast uh that stuff helps us
get to uh the packs uh showing time so
uh trust me it's going to be a thing
like yeah it's a real big thing I've
been getting like a lot of emails here
lately about packs a ton of that stuff
I've been doing a lot of bookings I've
been uh checking all the games that's
going to be there
tons of Studios have hit me up uh so
like just getting your ducks in order
and trying to hit in those three days
trying to hit 150 Studios and give you
at least 200 games of information and
and stuff that boots on the ground
not regurgitated information that other
people give people and as they go sort
through and look through on the internet
without even the comfort of their home
you know we're outside in the freezing
cold in Boston doing what we got to do
and you know working as hard as we can
possibly can to bring you the best
information and that stuff goes up to
Lords of gaming.net where you can find
the finest writers and best opinion
pieces in the game thank you so much for
coming through today and uh at it see
you next week brother yeah and what I
want you guys to do you know we got some
people in the chat right now go over
there and uh and Ray because I can't
raid them because uh YouTube has like
weird conditions go the radar man Neo
man uh okay save something on Sparks for
me yeah go over there tell Neo Sparks
that uh that the Lord sent you man go
over there and chat it up with him and
until